in arguably the biggest evidence of
obstruction of justice by President
Donald Trump since the firing of former
FBI director James Comey the New York
Times is reporting the bombshell
allegation that Donald Trump ordered
Robert Muller the special prosecutor be
fired we've been talking for the last
couple of months about what has held
Trump back from ordering Muller fire
does Trump realize that it would be a
disastrous thing in terms of the optics
or just Trump realize that it actually
might be obstruction of justice to go
and fire Robert Mulder what is it that
has kept Trump from firing Moeller and
it turns out the answer is nothing has
kept Trump from ordering the firing of
Robert Muller but when he did order the
firing in last June the White House
Counsel threatened to resign rather than
actually go through and fire Robert
Muller and then that made Donald Trump
sort of back off I'm talking about
Trump's White House lawyer Don Magan who
straight-up refused to tell the Justice
Department to go ahead and fire a
special prosecutor Robert Muller when
Trump told him to do it and said I will
quit if you force me to tell the Justice
Department to fire Robert Muller an
innocent person cooperates with the
investigation
they don't order every higher up
involved that they can imagine fired or
tell someone else to go and fire them
and of course some trumpets are calling
the story itself fake news in fact Fox
News's Sean Hannity was and we'll talk
about that a little bit later on in the
program but as is often the case with
Donald Trump and most of the the times
that he has said the New York Times
reporting has been fake news is actually
really well sourced and super specific
reporting from the New York Times Trump
said quote fake news folks fake news a
typical New York Times fake story
well that so-called fake story from the
New York Times included the details that
when Donald Trump found out that Robert
Muller was looking at obstruction of
justice charges Trump said that there
were conflicts about Robert Muller that
should get him
tired and Trump apparently was reminded
of or remembered that there was once a
dispute where Robert Muller was a member
at one of Donald Trump's golf clubs and
ended up canceling his membership
because he wasn't happy about some kind
of fee and that apparently in Donald
Trump's mind constituted such a conflict
of interest that Robert Muller should be
released from his role as special
prosecutor
Trump also said Muller couldn't possibly
be impartial because he had most
recently worked for a law firm that
represented Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner which in my mind if anything
that's a conflict that works in Trump's
favor in some way doesn't it yeah and
Muller is a top-tier lawyer and these
are top tier clients that we're talking
about yeah it's gonna be some conflict
no matter where you go I would think so
a top rating at that level and that's
not everything
Trump not only ordered Muller fired but
he also ordered his own staff to start
smearing the people at the FBI that
would be able to confirm early on that
Trump was trying to end the Russia
investigation foreign policy is
reporting yet another well sourced and
well done report that Trump once this
investigation got going ordered his top
political and legal staff to start smear
campaigns against people at the FBI that
would likely be part of Robert molars
investigation against him and that would
know that Trump was actively trying to
end that investigation this includes the
current deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe who he also was recently
pressuring Jeff Sessions to have fired
it includes James commis chief of staff
Jim rebecky it includes former FBI
general counsel James Baker The
Washington Post in addition to the
foreign policy report and in addition to
the New York Times report The Washington
Post has since also independently
confirmed the story by The Times which
again Donald Trump wrote off as fake
news and I want to bring your attention
to something that now two major
newspapers are reporting six months ago
or several months ago
Kellyanne Conway and John Dowd and
himself all lied in interviews about
firing Robert Muller on August 6 to
George Stephanopoulos Kelly Conway said
quote he has not even discussed that
meaning the firing of Muller the
president has not discussed firing Bob
Muller that was in August turns out that
was a lie because Trump ordered Muller
fired in June in USA today on August 8th
John Dowd said quote that's never been
on the table never it's a manifestation
of the media we now know that two months
prior Donald Trump ordered the firing of
Robert Muller and Trump himself on
August 10th was asked by a gaggle about
the firing of Robert Muller and he said
quote I haven't given it any thought you
could say maybe Kellyanne Conway didn't
know that Trump had done this you could
say maybe John Dowd didn't know that
Trump had done this but Donald Trump
himself surely knew on August 10th that
in June he himself had ordered Robert
Muller fired right this is the clearest
case for obstruction of justice so far
and Trump has lied about it further
incriminating himself yeah we really are
seeing this like new crop emerging of
secondary crimes that Trump and others
are committing yep you look at
obstruction of justice whether it be him
firing Comey or trying to pressure Jeff
Sessions to resign now ordering the
firing of Robert Muller and then you can
adds that you know if he was to have an
interview with Muller could he lie in
that interview could he perjure himself
lie to the FBI and you know the only
reason you do all that stuff is because
you're hiding something yeah again if
Trump instead of the tweets and all of
the sidebar stuff had only ever said
about Russia
we're cooperating with the investigation
and we'll continue advancing our
legislative agenda until such time that
the investigation of finalizes a lot of
this stuff never would have happened and
even Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
says that yeah this is something we have
to look into this attempt to fire Robert
Muller is something that should become
part of Robert Moeller's investigation
here he is yesterday on ABC's this week
I don't know I believe is something that
Muller should look at we're not going to
just say it's fake news and move on
Muller is the best person to look at it
not me opine about
thing I don't know I'm sure that
there'll be an investigation around
whether or not President Trump did try
to fire mr. Muller we know that he
didn't fire mr. Muller we know that if
he tried to be the end of his presidency
so at the end of the day let mr. Muller
do his job the ways in which this entire
investigation is mirroring the
investigation that ultimately took down
President Richard Nixon is truly
stunning the first count in Richard
Nixon's articles of impeachment was
obstruction of justice and what set that
off was when Richard Nixon ordered the
firing of the independent special
prosecutor Archibald Cox that led to the
resignations of the then Attorney
General and the then Deputy Attorney
General during Watergate and you know
the rest and it's it's getting sort of
cliche to even say it but it's often not
the crime it's the cover-up it may
actually be both here but this is not
looking good whatsoever the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership